Keith you and Bill have known each other
for some years you've worked together on
on some projects before what made you
feel comfortable and confident that bill
was at a point where he was ready to
direct a feature and make it go okay uh
you know the thing about it is if you
know Bill you know that he is a great
storyteller to begin with and the first
thing as a producer you're really
looking for from a director or in a
director is someone who could tell a
story weave together a story in a in a
in in the right way the information
comes when it's supposed to calm or in
an interesting way bill is just a great
storyteller so that's the first clue but
the other thing is you know you have
multiple conversations about film and
cinema and story and you get a good
sense of people's salt and Bill is one
of those guys that he just knows
everything there is to know about story
and I'm damn proud of him when it came
to finding department heads on this film
did you reach out to people that you
remembered having good experiences with
on sets as an actor how did you choose
your crew I found myself going
brain-dead I couldn't remember any body
that I had worked with I could remember
the last three people and they were all
busy so that was a really frightening
part of the process choosing the crew I
would talk to Keith would narrow it down
to three or four people and I would just
sort of go with a gut feeling and it
worked it worked really really well we
had a real nice trust and vibe in prep I
knew the line producer instantly we
wanted to work with and I knew right
away as did bill that we needed to find
somebody that was capable of identifying
songwriters and musicians that could
submit music from a wide casted net in
the indie music scene so we got a music
supervisor that I had worked with before
and then you know Tyler and Gary by
co-producers and I a real photography
enthusiast and so we we basically put
bill
the phone with a lot of really really
fantastic DPS many of whom are huge fans
of his and all of whom wanted to shoot
the film so it it was like that and and
bill was able to talk to people but I
think that by and large we made a lot of
really good choices if you look at the
credits two names that pop up a lot if
I'm gonna remember them correctly Simon
Stedman and charlton Pettis well done
and they're the guys who wrote most of
the original songs that the vent miles
heizer character wrote and the band
sings these guys are amazing did you
guys like the music it is really really
difficult to find people that are both
talented in the music space and capable
of doing what actors do consuming
themselves with the character and
writing from that perspective they would
say no it's not but it really is and you
should know them they they have a group
called solid-state but they're really
ultimately musicians that produce they
produce music for famous famous acts and
what about all those great open mic
people you know the girl from Oklahoma
with the exception of Kate Micucci who's
a pal and she wrote don't call me horror
in the morning i love boots I mean these
people must have been so excited at the
opportunity if they're local Oklahoma
musicians to do this yeah were you were
you very selective did you audition
dozens and dozens of people and just for
the six that we're right doesn't doesn't
yeah yeah dozens and dozens you
basically were Simon Cowell yes yeah I
was like I would go out because I tend
to like a cocktail now and again I would
hit the local scene and I would just
start you know saying you know Bill Macy
wants you know uh we we had a kalokohan
and they would come in and bill and I
would sit there and we try to be very
very bland but people would roll these
big tubas in and start playing and it
was just a bizarre scene somewhere so
wonderfully bad to that guy that I my
character goes up and says i love it
when women break your heart that song is
so funny he's a lovely guy but that's
really a
came into the audition room and and and
went for it and he was really bleeding
his heart out and it really terrible we
wanted to laugh and I did actually it
builds assistant and I who are good
friends really were laughing at there is
a moment where laurence fishburne's
character says to Billy's character it's
so great what you're doing for that boy
and is that was there more to it in in
an earlier draft that that didn't make
the final cut as to what he was
referring to really besides just a
troubled past he's a smart lad there was
another scene there that was one of
those meltdown days but ended
beautifully ended beautifully we had
shot some of that scene in the guitar
Emporium and we were after lunch going
to do another part of the scene when
some actor actors said why would I say
that and if everyone hit the whole
script fell apart the scene that we had
didn't make sense it's amazing how that
can happen to you at any rate over lunch
we talked about what's the essence here
and that's where that scene was born and
Billy plated beautifully it was so
inspiring I gotta tell you I don't think
of it as negative at all I like conflict
like that I really do and the writers
were there Tyler myself Gary bill fish
it was beautiful in that scene Billy all
of them took so much pleasure and
confidence in all of us for being
willing to say stop hang on a minute
here wait a second that's a really great
point and I think that that scene really
flew after that and I think vicious
character really flew after that there's
a story that I've read in an interview
that you guys did that I would like the
audience to hear which is about the
scene near the end with the the radio
block party where the band is about to
perform
firm and you as director were a little
worried about the cost and how can you
finish that story yes that black party
that's pretty big we had that stage and
all those speakers and all the the the
vendors who had set up all of that stuff
they were trucked it was expensive and i
said to our designer he came up and he
said what do you think this scene costs
and i said 50 grand he said no and I
said a hundred grand he said no and I
said 25 grand he said no I said okay it
was free he said no I said I give up he
said we made five grand everything was
free and they sold all the grizzly bear
or grizzly bear rotstein Mustang beer
and they gave his five grand and a bunch
of beer in putting this together or in
the release of it or let's say at
Sundance for instance when you premiered
there have you had the opportunity to
reach out to families or people who are
along the lines of the Billy and
Felicity characters or that not
something that you wanted to do her felt
you should two or three people have come
up and said I met a young man who said
my sister was a Columbine there have
been a couple of others who were touched
by it and they came up it's very hard to
find these people they they disappear
and I as much as I wanted to it after
the film was made it it could so easily
smack of exploitation and I we just
haven't done it it just what bills right
they the smartest thing he has said on
this entire press tour is that these
parents aren't allowed to mourn families
of the shooters aren't allowed to mourn
it's virtually impossible to find them
but also people that are victims because
of the
media age that we live in whether it's
somebody that was abducted and suddenly
found or whether they were involved in
something like Columbine they want to
disappear because they don't want their
life to be forever defined or connected
to this incident that they didn't sign
up for and so it's very very difficult
to find them and you know our film is
really just pointing a camera at a
corner of a story that or a subject that
we don't often think about a parent
getting that call that's enough really
it really is one final thing before we
say goodnight when you guys watch the
film do you watch it and think while we
did it or do you watch it and think I
wish I'd done this or how do you allow
yourself to be when you watch it me I've
gotten to that place where I'm done
seeing all the people that I know her
hiding around corners I'm done seeing
the cuts before and after we made
decisions I'm done remembering things I
truly just sink in and enjoy this film
and I'm not promoting it I truly believe
that I get emotional every single time I
see Billy sing that last song I get
really really fond of those three young
boys in the band I toe tap to every one
of the songs because that's music that
really inspires me so I'm I'm different
I really love it it's a brand new thing
for me this whole directing thing so I
perhaps a little more introspective to
figure out what I did right what I did
wrong what I want to do differently
going forward because I would like to do
this some more but luckily the with
chops with maturity comes this knowledge
that you gotta you gotta move forward
there's nothing more vicious than acting
the scene in the car on the way home
again the way you wish you had done it I
mean that way lies and madness so is
somebody said would you change anything
in the film and I said well more to the
point I would keep some stuff in
film but I'm it's out there it's done
and I'm I'm happy I'm I was a great
experience for me a great experience it
got me out of my comfort zone I've
fallen in love with the business all
over again in a 14 year old sloppy way
and I'm charged up like I've been for a
long long time so I'm pleased as punch
and it can live on its own now I look
forward to the next one to thank you so
much Billy keep a great night